this cast iron pan I found on Facebook
Marketplace may be someone's trash but
soon it will be my treasure let's
restore it
[Music]
the first step is to bathe your cast
iron in a solution of water and white
vinegar for an hour after sprinkle the
pan with baking soda scrub the pan with
a non-scratch sponge until all the rust
is gone I like using Scotch Brite's
non-scratch scrub sponge
dry the pan off with a paper towel and
place it over a high flame until it's
dry
use a flaxseed oil to remove the thin
Sheen of rust that forms after drying
then wipe it off with a paper towel
rub it down again with a generous layer
of oil then rub the oil off with a paper
towel until there's just a thin layer
left
put your cast iron in the oven at 500
degrees Fahrenheit upside down for one
hour take the pan out and revel in your
good as new season cast iron
foreign